نقلت وكاله اسرشيت برست عن البيت الابيض
قوله انه وزاره العدل تراجع مجموعه من
الوثائق يحتمل ان تكون سريه تم العثور
عليها في مكتب كان يتبع لرئيس بايضا في
العاصمه واشنطن قبيله تسلل بمهامه رئيسا
للبلاد واوضح ريتشارد سوبر المستشار الخاص
بوليضا ان الوثائق تحمل وسم السريه ووقعت
بين ايدي محامي الرئيس الحالي عند اخلاء
مكتبه بعد انتهائه ولايته نائبا للرئيس
اوباما عام 2017 واضاف المستشار ان اداره
المحفوظات والسجلات الوطنيه ابلغت فورا
وسلمت لها الوثائق في اليوم الثالث
هذا ونقلته وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه عن
رئيس مجلس النواب كيفما كارتي وصفه العثور
على وثائق السريه بمكتب كانت تابعه
لجوبايدا بانه امر مقلق جدا واتهم
الديمقراطيه بالمبالغه في رد فعلهم ازاء
ما فعله الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب مسبقا
كانت هذه الوثائق السريه
بعد انقضاء هذه السنوات لقد بلغ
الديمقراطيون بعد الكشف عن وثائق في اقامه
ترامب في مارغو